alexis lacroix vous avez une
responsabilité un dans le dans le lent
quitte rapidement biomasse que j'ai
souvenir de couverture de l'express pas
très sympathique qui mettait presque en
doute la santé mentale du président des
responsabilités non mais vous recevrez
qu'on a reflété les inquiétudes d'un
certain nombre d'américains dont les
élites politiques américaines et
d'intellectuels américaine il ya un
inquiétudes qui je crois est légitime
sur alors la santé mentale c'est un peu
excessif mais ils ont sur la normalité
de comportement de donald trump
je crois que c'est une question
démocratique il est légitime de relayer
donc de ce point de vue là nous n'avons
pas de responsabilité dans la forme
d'anti trump ispo radical que je vais à
mon tour dénoncé je suis extrêmement
choquée à titre personnel comme
spectateur engagé par la une de society
que vous venez de nous montrer c'était
une si vous voulez représente c'est un
déchet intellectuelle radicale du
pacifisme français de l'éternel
pacifisme français qui se trompe à
chaque époque sur les enjeux essentiels
et là je rejoins denis c'est vrai qu'on
peut faire toutes les critiques que l'on
veut sur la ligne politique de trump est
également sur son comportement
en revanche ce qui est absolument
indéniable c'est que trump et le
représentant d'une puissance
démocratique
le monsieur qui est europe qui
représenté sur cette une
à ses côtés c'est le chef d'une tyrannie
sanguinaire dont ces mises en
équivalence me rappelle notamment celles
qui avaient lieu
lorsqu'on a abattu le régime de saddam
hussein souvenez-vous nous étions tous
les deux dans le même groupe de presse
il y avait des gens qui pensaient au nom
si vous voulez delà des lignes a des
liens historiques de la france avec le
régime de saddam hussein
qu'il fallait renvoyer dos-à-dos georgia
belliot bouche et saddam hussein j'ai
toujours trouvé personnellement cette
position scandaleuse
c'est une position de pétainiste de
gauche donc je trouve que la n2 social
qui est très grave
elle est grave ici et elle risque
d'avoir du succès malheureusement dans
les tréfonds de la confiance